WE WILL COVER THAT AND SO
MUCH MORE.
WE ARE GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
WHAT IS ALMOST UNPRECEDENTED
MOVE PRESIDENT TRUMP INVITED
LAWMAKERS TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY AND PEELED BACK THE
CURTAINS TO ALLOW TV CAMERAS
IN THE ROOM TO CAPTURE
DEBATE ON IMMIGRATION.
MANY OF YOU WERE UNABLE TO
WATCH THIS PLAY OUT IN FULL.
WE WILL PLAY LARGE PORTIONS
STARTED OFF THE DISCUSSION
SAYING BORDER SECURITY HAS
TO COME FIRST IN ANY DEAL.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
ADVANCE BIPARTISAN
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT
SERVES THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN FAMILIES, WORKERS,
AND TAXPAYERS IT'S DACA.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IT FOR A LONG TIME.
I HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT IT
FOR YEARS LONG BEFORE I
DECIDED TO GO IN THIS
PARTICULAR LINE OF WORK AND
MAYBE WE CAN DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
GREAT SPIRIT FOR TAKING CARE
OF PEOPLE WE REPRESENT.
WE ALL REPRESENT.
FOR THAT REASON, ANY
LEGISLATION ON DACA WE FEEL,
AT LEAST A STRONG PART OF
THIS GROUP FEELS HAS TO
ACCOMPLISH THREE VITAL
GOALS.
CHAIRMAN GOOD LATH WILL BE
SUBMITTING A BILL OVER THE
NEXT TWO TO THREE DAYS THAT
WILL COVER MANY OF THE
THINGS AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
OUT.
I FEEL HAVING THE DEMOCRATS
IN WITH US IS ABSOLUTELY
VITAL BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE A
BIPARTISAN BILL.
IT SHOULD BE A BILL OF LOVE,
TRULY, SHOULD BE A BILL OF
LOVE AND WE CAN DO THAT.
BUT IT ALSO HAS TO BE A BILL
WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO SECURE
OUR BORDER, DRUGS ARE
POURING INTO OUR COUNTRY AT
A RECORD PACE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN THAT WE CAN'T HAVE.
WE HAVE GREATLY STIFFENED AS
YOU KNOW AND FEWER PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO COME IN BUT WE
HAVE TREMENDOUS NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE AND DRUGS POURING
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
SO, IN ORDER TO SECURE IT,
WE NEED A WALL, WE NEED
CLOSING ENFORCEMENT.
WE HAVE TO CLOSE ENFORCEMENT
AND THESE ARE TREMENDOUS
PEOPLE, THE BORDER SECURITY
AGENTS, THE ICE AGENTS.
WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE
AND THIS REALLY DOES INCLUDE
A VERY STRONG AMOUNT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
I THINK EVERYBODY IN THE
QUESTION OF AMOUNTS BUT I
THINK EVERYONE AGREES WE
HAVE TO HAVE BORDER
SECURITY.
I DON'T THINK THERE WOULD BE
ANYBODY THAT SAYS NO.
SECOND, IT HAS TO BE A BILL
TO END CHAIN MIGRATION.
CHAIN MIGRATION IS BRINGING
WORK OUT VERY WELL.
THOSE MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT
DOING US RIGHT.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM AND I'M NOT SURE
CAN I SPEAK FOR EVERYBODY
BUT A LOT OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM WANT TO SEE CHAIN
MIGRATION ENDED AND WE HAVE
A RECENT CASE ALONG THE WEST
SIDE HIGHWAY HAVING TO DO
WITH CHAIN MIGRATION WHERE A
MAN RAN OVER, KILLED 8
LOSS OF LEGS.
HORRIBLE THING HAPPENED.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CHAIN AND ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT CAME IN BECAUSE OF HIM,
TERRIBLE SITUATION.
PUT NAMES IN A HOPPER.
THEY ARE NOT GIVING YOU
THEIR BEST NAMES.
COMMON SENSE MEANS THEY ARE
NOT GIVING YOU THEIR BEST
NAMES.
THEY ARE GIVING YOU PEOPLE
TONIGHT REMEMBER THIS IS THE
SAME PRESIDENT THAT THE
MEDIA AND EVERY DEMOCRAT HAS
BEEN TELLING YOU FOR DAYS
AND WEEKS AND IN SOME CASES
MONTHS IS ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
NO, HE WAS VERY ENGAGED.
HE WAS TOTALLY IN CHARGE.
AND BEING TRANSPARENT,
EXTREMELY PATIENT AND COMMON
HE WAS GIVING YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, A RARE
GLIMPSE INTO AN HISTORIC
PROCESS ON THE IMPORTANT
ALL THE PRESIDENT TWEETED AS
OF THE WALL ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, WHICH MUST BE A PART
OF ANY DACA APPROVAL.
THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY NOW
REFUSING TO BACK DOWN ON
BUILDING THE BORDER WALL.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS
MONTHS AND YEARS IN ORDER
FOR THE G.O.P. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, YOU GUYS WANT TO
WIN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
BUILD TWO OR THREE HUNDRED
MILES OF THE BORDER WALL.
GO DOWN THERE AND CUT YOUR
COMMERCIALS.
PROMISE MADE, PROMISE KEPT.
VOTERS HAPPY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
SEE TANGIBLE RESULTS AND
NOVEMBER.
THIS HAS TO BE FUND THE
WALL, BUILD THE WALL FIRST,
BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS LIKE OH,
YOU GET THE TAX INCREASE,
YOU NEVER GET THE SPENDING
CONSIDERATION, THE AMNESTY,
WHATEVER IT HAPPENS TO BE,
THE WALL NEVER GETS BUILT.
WE HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS RODEO
BEFORE.
YOU REPUBLICANS, YOU WANT TO
WIN IN NOVEMBER?
YOU ARE UP FOR ELECTION, NOT
DONALD TRUMP.
PUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, PUT
THEIR SECURITY FIRST AND
PROMISES.
AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
REMARKS, DEMOCRATS THEY
ALL THEY CARE IS AMNESTY,
DACA, ANNUAL NECESSITY AND
DACA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE FOR
SECURITY AT THE BORDERS.
I WANT TO STATE THAT
EMPHATICALLY.
THERE IS NOT A DEMOCRAT THAT
IS NOT FOR HAVING SECURE
BORDERS.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENCES, HOWEVER,
MR. PRESIDENT, ON HOW YOU
AFFECT THAT YOU JUST
INDICATED THAT YOURSELF.
AND YOU INDICATED THIS WOULD
BE A FIRST STEP AND THEN WE
CONTINUE TO TALK AS WE ARE
TALKING TODAY ABOUT HOW WE
BEST SECURE THE BORDER THERE
ARE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
WITHIN YOUR PARTY AND OUR
PARTY.
I WOULD URGE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD ON PROTECTING THE
DACA PROTECTED INDIVIDUALS.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOUNG ADULTS AS YOU POINTED
OUT IN ONE OF YOUR
STATEMENTS WHO ARE
PRODUCTIVE PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
THAT WE PROTECT THEM AND GET
THAT DONE AND THEN, BECAUSE
I THINK EVERYBODY AROUND THE
TABLE AS YOU POINTED OUT IS
WE BEST AFFECT THAT BORDER
SECURITY.
I WOULD URGE US TO MOVE AS
SENATOR DURBIN HAS JUST
MOVED ON THE DACA STUDENTS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE
SPEAKER, I THINK TODAY BUT
MAYBE YESTERDAY SAID WE NEED
TO SOLVE THE DACA ISSUE AND
WE NEED TO SOLVE IT IN A WAY
THAT IS PERMANENT NOT
TEMPORARY.
AND I AGREE WITH HIM ON THAT
ISSUE.
WHEN HE SIGNED THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ACTUALLY SAID HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THIS AND SO YOU DO HAVE TO
GO THROUGH CONGRESS AND YOU
DO HAVE TO MAKE IT
DOESN'T, LET'S ASSUME HE
DOESN'T.
HE SAID IT AND THAT WAS A
TEMPORARY STOP GAP.
STRONGLY.
THAT THE SENATE PASSED A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
BILL, AS YOU KNOW.
WE DID NOT CONSIDER IT IN
THE HOUSE SO WE DIDN'T REACH
THOSE ISSUES.
VERY FRANKLY ON BORDER
SECURITY SOLUTION, WHICH WE
THEN INCLUDED IN THE BILL
THAT WE FILED ON
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
SO I THINK WE CAN REACH
AGREEMENT.
>> I ALSO THINK AFTER WE DO
DACA AND I REALLY BELIEVE WE
SHOULD BE SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK WE SHOULD LOOK IN
TERMS OF YOUR PERMANENT
SOLUTION AND TO THE WHOLE
SITUATION WITH IMMIGRATION.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM WOULD AGREE TO
THAT ALSO.
WE WILL DO IT IN STEPS AND
MOST PEOPLE AGREE WITH THAT
I THINK.
AND THEN WE GO PHASE II.
KEVIN, WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY?
>> WELL, FIRST, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
I LIKE THE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS.
I THINK EVERYBODY HAS A
POINT HERE.
THE ONE THING I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN HERE IS WHAT
I SAW IN THE PAST.
THERE WERE FORMER BILLS THAT
WERE PASSED ON BORDER
SECURITY YEARS AGO THAT
NEVER GOT FINISHED.
THERE ARE IMMIGRATION BILLS
PASSED THAT WERE RIGHT BACK
ON THE TABLE WITH THE SAME
EACH ONE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT WHEN WE GET DONE AND
COME TO AN AGREEMENT, THAT
WE'RE NOT BACK AT THIS
PROBLEM THREE, FOUR YEARS
FROM NOW.
THAT'S WHY YES, WE HAVE GOT
TO DO DACA AND I AGREE WITH
YOU 100 PERCENT.
BUT IF WE DO NOT DO
SOMETHING WITH THE SECURITY,
IF WE DO NOT DO SOMETHING
WITH THE CHAIN MIGRATION, WE
ARE FOOLING EACH OTHER THAT
WE SOLVED A PROBLEM.
SO LET'S COLLECTIVELY, WE'RE
TELL YOU WE ARE ALL GOING TO
WILLING TO.
BUT LET'S SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THAT IT IS SOLVED WHEN IT'S
NOT.
>> Sean: GREAT POINTS BY
KEVIN MCCARTHY.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE OTHER
BIG MOMENTS FROM TODAY'S
IMMIGRATION DEBATE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> THE COUNTRY IS DOING WELL
IN SO MANY WAYS BUT THERE IS
SUCH DIVISIVENESS, SUCH
DIVISION AND I REALLY
BELIEVE WE CAN SOLVE THAT.
I THINK THIS SYSTEM IS A
VERY BAD SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
GETTING TOGETHER AND I'M
GOING TO LEAVE IT UP TO YOU
BUT I REALLY BELIEVE CAN YOU
DO SOMETHING TO BRING IT
TOGETHER.
>> OTHER THAN GOING TO
DINNER WITH BOB I HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR 10 YEARS.
I DON'T SEE A BETTER CHANCE
JOHN IS RIGHT, I'M NOT GOING
TO SUPPORT A BILL IF YOU
DON'T SUPPORT IT I HAVE HAD
MY HEAD BEAT OUT A BUNCH.
HOW COULD I COULD ELECTED I
HAVE BEEN PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR 11 MILLION
PEOPLE BECAUSE I HAVE NO
AMOSS CITY TOWARDS THEM.
I DON'T WANT CORROBORATION
OR BAD HOMBRES I WANT TO GET
MERIT BASED IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
SUCCEED IN THE 21ST CENTURY.
I'M WILLING TO BE MORE THAN
EVERY 20 YEARS.
>> CHAIN MIGRATION HAS TAKEN
A VERY BIG HIT IN THE LAST
YEAR WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING.
YOU LOOK AT THESE KILLERS,
WHETHER YOU LIKE OR NOT,
LOOKING AT THESE KILLERS AND
30 PEOPLE CAME IN WITH THIS
ONE PERSON THAT JUST KILLED
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I REALLY DON'T BELIEVE THERE
ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
CHAIN MIGRATION ANYMORE.
>> SHOULD WE HAVE THE
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY?
>> IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST A
COUPLE THINGS ON BORDER
SECURITY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
SECURITY IS SO IMPORTANT TO
HAVE AS PART OF THIS
WE CAN APPREHEND PEOPLE BUT
WE CAN'T REMOVE THEM.
SO WE NEED THE WALL SYSTEM,
WHICH IS SOME PHYSICAL
STRUCTURE AS THE PRESIDENT
DESCRIBED, FOCUSED ON
TECHNOLOGY BUT WE HAVE TO
CLOSE THOSE LEGAL LOOPHOLES
BECAUSE THE EFFECT OF THIS
IS INCREDIBLE PULL UP FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA THAT
CONTINUES TO EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM.
BORDER SECURITY HAS TO BE
PART OF THIS OR HE WILL BE
HERE AGAIN IN THREE, FOUR,
FIVE YEARS AGO.
MAYBE UNFORTUNATELY SOONER.
>> I WANT TO REEMPHASIZE
WHAT SECRETARY NIELSEN SAID,
ABOUT BORDER SECURITY IF YOU
APPREHEND SOMEBODY AT THE
BORDER BUT THEN YOU CANNOT
SEND THEM BACK OUTSIDE THE
UNITED STATES, EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE UNLAWFULLY PRESENT
IN THE UNITED STATES, YOU
HAVE NOT SOLVED THIS PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE THEN
RELEASED INTO THE INTERIOR
OF THE COUNTRY AND THE
PROBLEM PERSISTS AND THAT
SENDS A MESSAGE BACK TO
WHEREVER THEY HAVE COME
FROM.
COME DO IT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT WE WILL
NEGOTIATE THAT.
>> I AGREE.
>> THE OTHER THING WE HAVE
GOT TO LOOK AT THE WALL
ITSELF, MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU TALK TO YOUR BORDER
PATROL CHIEF OR THE FORMER
BORDER PATROL CHIEF I HAVE
ASKED THEM HOW MUCH TIME
DOES THE WALL BUY YOU?
THEY WILL SAY A COUPLE
MINUTES OR A FEW SECONDS.
IT IS OUR OWN BORDER PATROL
CHIEFS THAT HAVE SAID THAT.
>> NOT MINE.
MINE HAS MADE CLEAR THE WALL
WORKS.
>> THEY SAY WITHOUT THE WALL
WE CANNOT HAVE BORDER
SECURITY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS ASK
>> ASK ME.
ASK SAN DIEGO.
>> HOMELAND APPROPRIATIONS,
YOUR CHIEF WAS THERE AND THE
FORMER CHIEFS HAVE ALL SAID
THAT NOW THE OTHER THING.
IF YOU LOOK AT -- THIS IS
WHERE THE WALL --
MR. PRESIDENT, IF YOU LOOK
AT WHERE THE WALLS ARE AT
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS WHERE THE
ACTIVITY IS WHERE THE WALLS
ARE AT RIGHT NOW.
>> WE HAVE MASSIVE MILES OF
AREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE
POURING THROUGH.
NOW, ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS
BECAUSE OF OUR RHETORIC OR
BECAUSE OF THE PERCEIVED,
YOU KNOW, MY PERCEIVED
ATTITUDE, FEWER PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO COME THROUGH,
THAT'S A GREAT THING.
AND, THEREFORE, OUR NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN FANTASTIC MAYBE
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS.
>> LET ME JUST FINISH MY
THOUGHT.
I WANTS TO ASK YOU THAT
WE'RE PLAYING -- YOU SAW THE
GAME LAST NIGHT IT WAS A
GOOD GAME LAST NIGHT.
>> VERY GOOD.
>> WE ARE PLAYING DEFENSE ON
THE ONE YARD LINE CALLED THE
U.S. BORDER.
WE SPEND OVER $18 BILLION A
YEAR ON THE BORDER.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT MEXICO
HAS DONE, THEY STOP
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH
GUATEMALA.
WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT --
>> -- WE STOPPED THEM.
NOT AS MANY PEOPLE ARE
COMING THROUGH THEIR
SOUTHERN BORDER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T THINK THEY CAN GET
THROUGH OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AND THEREFORE THEY DON'T
COME.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
MEXICO.
>> WE ACTUALLY PUT
APPROPRIATIONS TO HELP WITH
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> THE POINT IS I KNOW WE
ALWAYS GIVE EVERYBODY, EVERY
OTHER NATION GETS MONEY BUT
OURS.
WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
NATIONS.
>> FINALLY THE LAST.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP THAT.
>> INSTEAD OF PLAYING
DEFENSE ON THE ONE YARD
LINE.
IF I LOOK, WE KNOW WHERE THE
HOUSES ARE AT.
WE KNOW WHERE THE HOTELS ARE
AT.
WOULD HE KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
ACROSS THE RIVER.
>> WE ARE GOING AFTER IT.
>> WHY PLAY DEFENSE ON THE
ONE YARD LINE.
>> WE ARE GOING AFTER THEM
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
>> ALL I'M SAY SOMETHING WE
FOCUS ON DACA, WE CAN WORK
ON THE OTHER THINGS
SEPARATELY ON SENSIBLE
BORDER SECURITY, LISTEN TO
THE FOLKS THAT ARE FROM THE
BORDER AND.
>> YOU FOLKS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION.
AND IF YOU DO I'M GOING TO
SIGN THAT SOLUTION.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SMART
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
REALLY SMART PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE GOOD PEOPLE, BIG HEARTS,
THEY WANT TO GET IT DONE.
I THINK ALMOST EVERYBODY, I
CAN THINK OF ONE OR TWO I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE BUT
THAT'S OKAY.
[LAUGHTER]
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
EVERYBODY WANTS A SOLUTION.
YOU WANT IT HENRY AND I WANT
>> NO.
THERE WOULDN'T BE.
>> THE WALL HAS TO BE THERE.
>> YOU NEED IT.
JOHN, YOU NEED THE WALL.
I MEAN, IT'S WONDERFUL.
I WOULD LOVE NOT TO BUILD A
WALL BUT YOU NEED THE WALL.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
THE ICE OFFICERS AND THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS I HAD
THEM JUST RECENTLY UP, THEY
SAY IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
WALL, YOU KNOW, IN CERTAIN
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE WALL,
YOU CANNOT HAVE SECURITY.
JUST CAN'T HAVE IT.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> Sean: IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE WALL, YOU WILL NEVER
NIELSEN MADE GREAT POINTS AS
YOU SAW IN THAT EXCHANGE AND
AS WE SAW TODAY THE
PRESIDENT AND EVEN SOME
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING THE
BORDER WALL HAS TO COME
FIRST.
TO ME, THAT'S THE RIGHT
ANSWER.
IT, YOU CAN MOVE FORWARD.
YOU CAN HAVE YOUR
DISCUSSIONS.
CHAIN MIGRATION, ALSO MUST
GO AWAY.
THE LOTTERY SYSTEM.
WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE LAST
YEAR MUST GO AWAY.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE MASSIVE
HYPOCRITES.
AND THEY ARE BEING EXPOSED
NOTHING BUT POLITICAL TUNE
OPPORTUNISTS.
I DOUBT ANYONE ELSE IN THE
MEDIA IS ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
THESE MASSIVE FLIP-FLOPS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I VOTED NUMEROUS TIMES
WHEN I WAS A SENATOR TO
SPEND MONEY TO BUILD A
BARRIER TO TRY TO PREVENT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
COMING IN.
YOU DO HAVE TO CONTROL YOUR
BORDERS.
>> WHERE IT WAS NECESSARY WE
DID SUPPORT SOME FENCING
AGENTS.
WE HAVE DONE WHAT BY ANY
FAIR ESTIMATE WOULD HAVE TO
CONCLUDE IS A GOOD JOB,
QUOTE SECURING THE BORDER.
>> PEOPLE WHO ENTERED THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT OUR
U.S. LEGALLY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
NEVER ACCEPT IMMIGRATION
REFORM UNLESS THEY TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS COMMITTED TO
ENDING FUTURE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION TO
END DACA WAS HEARTLESS, AND
IT WAS BRAINLESS.
IF THIS ORDER STANDS,
HUNDREDS, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WILL
BE RIPPED APART.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN BUSINESSES WILL
LOSE HARD-WORKING EMPLOYEES.
>> THOSE WHO ENTER OUR
COUNTRY LEGALLY AND THOSE
WHO EMPLOY THEM DISRESPECT
THE RULE OF LAW.
AND BECAUSE WE LIVE IN AN
AGE WHERE TERRORISTS ARE
CHALLENGING OUR BORDERS, WE
CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO POUR
INTO THE U.S. UNDETECTED,
UNDOCUMENTED, AND UNCHECKED.
>> IF THERE ARE DISRUPTIONS
IN THESE COUNTRIES, IF THERE
IS CONFLICT, IF THERE IS BAD
GOVERNANCE, IF THERE'S WAR,
IF THERE'S POVERTY, IN THIS
NEW WORLD THAT WE LIVE, IN
WE CAN'T ISOLATE OURSELVES.
WE CAN'T HIDE BEHIND A WALL.
>> Sean: SHOWS HOW FAR LEFT
BY THE WAY ANYONE ELSE GOING
TO POINT OUT THE HYPOCRISY?
I GUESS NOW THAT IT'S
OPPOSING THE POLICIES THEY
WERE PASSIONATELY SUPPORTING
EN MASSE.
NOW, FOXNEWS.COM HAS A GREAT
ARTICLE UP TODAY SHOWCASING
THE DEMOCRATS' BLATANT
HYPOCRISY ON IMMIGRATION.
DEMS CHANGE TUNE ON BORDER
WALL AFTER BACKING BARRIER
OH UNDER OBAMA.
AND THE REPORTING POINTS OUT
THAT FIVE YEARS AGO UNDER
BARACK OBAMA THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS VOTED TO
BUILD 700 MILES OF FENCING
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT'S PRESIDENT
IT'S TRESIDENT
IT'S THESIDENT
IT'S THE SDENT
IT'S THE SAMNT
IT'S THE SAMET
IT'S THE SAME AREA THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BORDER
WALL.
THEY DIDN'T GET IT DONE.
CALLED ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
AND MODERNIZATION ACT ALSO
INCLUDED $40 BILLION OVER A
DECADE TO STRENGTHEN BORDER
SECURITY MEASURES AND ALSO
CALL THE DOUBLING THE
NUMBER -- CALLED FOR
DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF
BORDER AGENTS TO BE HIRED.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD IDEA.
HERE'S WHAT THIS TELLS US
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
OPPOSITION TO WHAT PRESIDENT
IT'S ABOUT PLAYING POLITICS.
IDENTITY POLITICS.
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE
BORDER.
LEAST A DOZEN TIMES.
HORSEBACK, ALL TERRAIN
I HAVE DONE IT ALL.
BEING ARRESTED.
CEILING DRUGS THAT WERE
CONFISCATED.
I HAVE BEEN IN A DRUG
SMUGGLING TUNNEL AND MUCH
MORE.
THE PROBLEMS DOWN THERE ARE
REAL.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
BECAUSE THEY WOULD RATHER